hello everyone my name is Tim Paris and
I'm author of the 4-hour workweek how to
escape 9 to 5 live anywhere and join the
new rich you may have heard of it
on CBS on CNBC or seen it on the cover
of the Style section in New York Times
it's been number one on the New York
Times Wall Street Journal and
Businessweek mess our list this is what
it looks like and I wanted to explain a
few things clear up a few misconceptions
and answer some of the most common
questions people have about the 4-hour
workweek so the book really came out of
content for guest lectures that I gave
Princeton University beginning in 2003
twice a year and then my own experience
going from 80 hours per week in Silicon
Valley both as an employee and then
later as CEO down to less than 4 hours
per week and there are a few very common
questions the first is do I have to quit
my job or be a risk taker to use the
book and the answer is no you don't
because the book isn't about how to be
Tim Ferriss the book is about how to
create time whether that's removing
unpaid overtime in the evenings and
weekends or cutting down 10 hours 2030
hours per week and does not inherently
even require quitting your job you can
keep your job there case studies single
mothers with two three four children who
have jobs who are able to cut down on
let's say email consumption take
sabbaticals around the world all the way
up to the CEOs Lamborghini driving 21
year olds etc etc but there are many
different case studies for every risk
tolerance and your specific set of
objectives so it's more like a fait of
options for lifestyle design doesn't
require being a risk taker in any sense
do I have to be a single 20-something so
the first answer I think took care of
that but no you don't so again even
though I'm thirty years old and I do
have a mortgage and other
responsibilities but this is really an
exploration of case studies and
interviews that I did around the world
in about 15 months and looking at the
very specific small changes that you can
make to create time and reclaim that
personal life for yourself and design a
luxury lifestyle in here and now as
opposed to postponing it for retirement
20 or 30 years do I have to travel I
just want more time so I do love travel
I travel a lot I take 1 2 3 mini
retirements per year of about one to
three months in line overseas usually
you don't have to do that the goal is to
create time and then use it how you want
that could be spending more time with
your family at home
it could be exploring your hobbies
developing new businesses or it could be
travelling or it could be all those
things so it's it's entirely
customizable for your individual dreams
and goals etc and do I need to be born
rich no you don't
so the 4-hour workweek is often taken
too literally meaning that it doesn't
imply that you have to work just four
hours per week or that you would even
want to get four hours per week but the
reality is there are new tools available
to people in digital age like personal
outsourcing outsourcing your life to
people in India and Philippines etc for
$5 an hour that anyone can use even if
they make $30,000 a year to
significantly multiply the lifestyle
impact of their income and that's what
this book explores and last but not
least can I really work four hours per
week you can and certainly it depends on
your circumstances but it's not an
impossibility but like I said before
whether you simply want to stop working
on the weekends and in the evenings are
cut back from let's say 80 hours per
week to 60 or 40 hours per week or if
you want to take it to an extreme level
and do some of the things that I've done
and some of the the more exciting
controversial case studies have done you
can bring it down to 38 20 and even yes
4 hours per week but you don't have to
you can push it as far as you want to
push it even if it's just a few small
changes that enable you to let's say
check email once
instead of every five minutes on your
blackberry so I hope that helps and this
is the book no detail is spared nothing
else is sold in the book it's all here
this is a manual it's a blueprint from
getting from where you are now to
reclaiming time and designing a
lifestyle that includes mobility time
and all the other currencies that are
important in a digital world in addition
to simply income so I hope you enjoy it
have a very happy holidays and thanks
for listening